present the awards for art direction  instead decoration two of this year's  nominees for their performances in Pete  Kelly's Blues and mr. Roberts ladies and  gentlemen I'm very proud to present miss  Peggy Lee and mr. Jack Lemmon  four black-and-whites art direction and  set decoration the Rose Tattoo art  direction how pereira and Fendi Larson  decoration Thank You thick set  decoration Sam comer and Arthur French  for color art decoration and I beg your  pardon for color art direction and set  decoration winner picnic art direction  William Flannery and Joe Mellon  thank you very very much and forceps  decoration  rubber priestly  thank you very much